[Music]
how's it going bro
my name is and today we're looking at
sushant
singh raiput now i'm not going to
pretend like i knew who this guy was
but i recently found out about him and i
talked about him in a video in it and so
many
people freaked out this guy is a big
deal i
just watched some videos of him and i
thought he would seem like a really
interesting dude
unfortunately he passed away about a
month ago
so i just wanted to make this video to
kind of tribute him and
bring attention to him in his life if
that makes sense i don't know
i just think he's a cool dude i'm not
gonna pretend like oh i was the biggest
fan
no i had no idea who he was but i like
what i've seen
now for those who don't know he was a
big actor he was in movies like
detective biam keshi bakshi you ever
seen that one
he was big in india in bollywood
basically
uh he got a nomination for best actor
and
he's been in commercially successful
films like kedarnath
and yeah
his acting is cool enough all right but
i think what
is more impressive about him is the fact
that he's actually really smart
i found out that he was ranked number
seven
in the engineering exams in of all of
india
not bad i used to study engineering
myself so
i remember i was pride when i got the
highest out of 200 people
uh i feel like out of all of india it's
a little bit more of a
more of an achievement and he also what
i like about him
he came from humble beginnings as well
i'm not gonna try and force
like oh with this name it's i'm saying i
can relate to him that's all
like it's anything the same growing up
in sweden and india
sorry i just realized how this sounds
like
he was also national olympiad winner in
physics what smart dude basically
uh and you can tell just by listening to
him apparently i saw here he worked for
uh kapoor remember her that [ __ ] dumb
thing
i noticed uh sushant followed me on
instagram and i was so confused by it
i wonder if it was because i trolled
ekta i don't know
regardless he dropped that engineering i
dropped that
engineering to pursue his dream uh to
work in show business
and uh one of the videos the first one i
saw of him was
when he did this university talk which i
thought was super interesting and i
wanted to share with you guys today
because i think he had a lot of
really valuable lessons on life uh so
let's watch it
excuse me if i don't make sense excuse
me if i get a panic attack right now
but i'll try my best
[Applause]
yeah i became an actor because i had
a problem i was an introvert
you know i'm the youngest in my family
and i was so pampered in
my heart that when i used to step out i
didn't know how to deal with people so i
i
gradually i became this very shy
introvert kid
who could not talk well i still cannot
talk
here i go here i insert myself again i
can just relate to it
i was such an introvert as well i still
am but i found this medium through
youtube
to be extroverted and be this character
it's just been so fun i guess he got the
same way through acting
all right i would love to share my
journey with you my learning so in case
you decide to drop
out and join me in bollywood it will
come very handy
so i was thinking in the car what do i
talk about wait this guy wrote the
script for what he was gonna speak to
university on the car on the way there
that's impossible
but after deep clicking i i i zeroed
down into two things that i can actually
discuss about
these two things talk about
chasing your dreams and actually living
your dreams
which unfortunately nobody mentioned
to me when i was starting out that's
funny because i had the
absolute opposite advice given to me
people were like follow your dreams
pick what you want and i'm like nah i'm
gonna pick the job i hate
because money so those two things are
the biggest lie and the only truth
about success that i was told about
i don't remember what it said but i'll
tell you what i think
is that success has way more importance
i know it's easy for me to say
this but i think people put way too much
importance
on success itself if you're having fun
with what you're doing
then you're already successful and you
can sustain yourself anything beyond
that it's just unnecessary
i think at least money
plus recognition is equal to happiness
is equal to success was that the lie
because i totally agree
i feel like such a broken record because
i think i've said this so many times and
every time i say it
everyone gets so mad and i get it
everyone's situation is different
but it is a general assumption in
society that these things will lead to
happiness i'll just be
extra clear when i say this obviously if
you can't afford to pay your rent and
all these things yeah
it will help you you will get happier if
you get it but i'm speaking money and
excess
money and its multitude what people
dream about
people imagine what would it be like if
i had so much money like millions what
would i do that'd be crazy
you know people love to fantasize about
these things that's why the lottery
exists
and people like to find science what it
would mean to be
recognized or some someone of notoriety
and we generally see hollywood stars
shiny and smilingly and all that stuff
when it happens
absolutely nothing to do with that
uh your happiness i think so at least
obviously people react differently to
different things but
they are literally things that are just
like anything else
after a while they're not going to be as
appealing anymore there are
sensational pleasures essentially
they'll flee away
so let me begin by mentioning that i
come from a very
uh middle-class family and when i was
growing up
money was a big big big difference in my
life
same for me because my parents were so
successful they made a lot of money but
uh and i always felt like oh god i need
to live up to their standards i need to
get a job
just so i can be like them i know like
boohoo me right
i'm just saying there was a lot of
pressure to perform well in that regard
and it wasn't until i decided you know
what i'm just gonna go on my own path
where
i actually found a lot more of it
ironically generations of my family that
i
know of that are documented nobody knew
what
fame uh felt like so basically
uh both uh money and recognition
were missing when i started out so i
already started out as a failure
let me be very precise my family told me
that i had to become an engineer
examination and then probably yeah that
would be
like opening the doors for all kinds of
happiness and i'll be forever
successful i'll be forever happy this is
the action
that i experienced
all right fair enough sweden or india
it's the same apparently that's so funny
but right so i became very good in
studies
did fairly well in my time board exams
and then
off i went to delhi for my classroom got
myself a drawn in a nice
school and uh with them there and
fiji and half a dozen of our
other coaching institutes and i used to
share my room with three other similar
aspirants
what it meant was every day after
finishing my
assignment school assignments and
preparing for my engineering entrance
exam
i had to wash my clothes and i had to
cook
food for myself i wasn't complaining
well it was worth it because after all i
was for the very first time in my life
i was so close to become
successful for the first time in my life
so yeah
finally i slopped i got selected for
several engineering colleges
and i decided to take a mission in delhi
college of engineering which is crazy
now known as gtu thank you
it's funny i got into my university
through entrance exams as well which i
worked really hard for
and it was like i got in it's crazy how
similar experience we had and i thought
as well like damn i made it like now
it's a smooth sailing from here
i could finally stop for a while and
breathe you know
i was telling myself that you know what
now you're made
you should be happy because you're
supposed to be happy
but it wasn't working that much
something was missing there was a void
that i could feel
so i i thought maybe something bigger
was required for some reason for some
reason
incidentally while uh the first 18 19
years of my life
the future of me was much happier
much successful than the president made
so like all right so i was forcing
myself
i promised uh as i promised i started
preparing the civil services examination
and i was forcing myself to slaughter uh
but i was bored
um exams were still far away
and the main time i thought of doing
theater and
uh i thought to learn dance because to
counter the
the shyness that i had still have
and also because there were no girls in
my engineering college for some reason
yeah so somebody told me that they are
very good-looking girls in
dance schools so i was like fine
there you have it just pick up dancing
and you'll meet girl scout
there you have it once i started
performing art
i knew one thing for sure
i knew that i quite liked it
and three years later imagine me sitting
in the campus
and i'm thinking all right i'm very
interested in performing arts
and all i want to do is to earn money
and to be recognized so if i become a
movie star
hmm i actually was very serious and i
dropped out of my couch
[Music]
no way he was that close wow
yeah i dropped that way sooner because
obviously i found youtube and i was
enjoying that so much more that
didn't feel like i lost to drop out the
idea was to just
quit quit school for a year and then
i'll come back
yep got heavily into theatre
and also the skills that i thought were
necessary
to become an actor and by the way this
time i stayed with
six other guys in a single room kitchen
but this time i was prepared for it
this time there was one difference i was
driven
that folks in engineering and b schools
should never become
so i had to prove a point to everybody i
had to prove a point
to my family most importantly
i had to prove a point to myself
and this was the time when i was also a
background dancer
so i was dancing behind all the possible
stars that you can think of
everybody and i was thinking i was
thinking to myself while i was
performing okay it's just three steps
away there and
everything will be solid and i kept
going like that
and two years later guess what
i got myself my first big break
i was selected for a prime time show on
a tv
now hear me out was a seriously a big
break
because i started earning right people
started recognizing me
to be honest i would deliberately go and
roam in all these malls
that's funny i don't think i've ever
done that done
i guess i did i did go on like make
videos where i broke his people
i also suddenly discovered that
i actually had many friends i'm like
what absent all this while but suddenly
they popped up
crazy how that works i was making good
money
to a point that money
stopped being a differentiator in my
life
[Music]
and i was becoming more and more popular
now
i cannot go to all these malls that i
was going
all alone right so i wanted somebody to
be with me to save me
that's the thing you don't realize first
time you get recognized is amazing you
love it it's so cool and that's
an experience everyone wants to feel but
then you almost feel isolated where you
can't go to
malls and you can't go to closely packed
areas anymore
you just feel like an alien it's very uh
limiting
the first dream house
i bought myself my dream car
and just a note volvo xc90 thank you
very much
to you as well i was getting such
female attention that my engineering
college friends
could only possibly fail got em
got em man
so i was having a time of my life
and then something unusual happened
i got used to everything
i felt cheated i stayed with
all these dreams for 10 and 15 years of
my life
i was promised happiness and i was
promised success
but all these things stayed with me
just for few days right i'm punctuating
me
because i started from zero money
and zero recognition so i was not happy
how could that it be
i didn't like this version of success
and the future me again was luring the
present me
but this time i decided
otherwise i would do something else
so that gets us to the second point
which is the only truth
yeah i think he said it pretty well it's
like he imagined these things happening
for 10
15 years of his life and then they
disappear in a couple days and i think
that's it they're nice to have and
everyone
wants to experience it but they don't
last and we put
way too much importance to them it's a
fantasy it's always greater in our head
i won't take too much time i'll just try
to keep it shut
i figured something i figured that
something
seemingly big things were not that big
once i got them and looking back
in the past i realized that
maybe smaller things were way bigger
and there was one thing that was missing
in my life
that was the cause of this illusion
and that thing that was missing
was now so true
yes i'll let him finish his sentence and
then i'll say what i want to say
i was all these years
just i was obsessed about what's going
to happen
we are taught in schools but if this
happens i'll do that
and uh six months from now i'll be here
so i wanted to be in control i was so
obsessed about my future oh my gosh
taking the entire responsibility about
the past
but all i was doing was frequently
swinging from past to future
i noticed the words he used control and
the presence or the
or now he was always looking for the
next thing and that's the problem with
with money and fame like
you will never have enough of it it's
something that you can chase forever but
there will never be enough
but i also think in general you know one
thing i noticed especially here on
youtube it's these channels that
make uh routine videos where they say oh
we wake up i wake up at
six i sleep four hours and then from six
to seven i do this and seven to eight i
do this and then and then
on and on and on and on and on and on
and i i get that those videos are very
inspiring
but being so focused on the things you
need to do constantly
seems like a nightmare to me i and i
think it's the illusion of control which
is what he said you want to think that
you have control over your future
when in reality it doesn't matter
happiness comes from the moment
and personally as well the more i find
myself in the moment
the better i'm doing it as a person i
really really strongly believe that
uh we always have this dream that we
want to chase oh if i do this then i'll
be happy
oh if i reach this goal then i'll be
happy what about now
anyone no matter who you are should be
able to be happy in the moment
that's the goal of life that's what we
should try and aim for
there's no always gracious greener or
situation that will make you feel better
why not just be happy now your life will
never be perfect
just recognize that and be happy for
what you have if you're in the moment
you immediately
realize and become thankful for the
things you do have instead of the things
that you don't have at least that's what
i notice
and i think meditating is a really good
technique to do that
but there are other ways as well of
course sorry this became a whole big
rant but i find that uh
especially today with it's so easy to
get distracted by things
you can occupy your mind constantly but
i think it's important to set away some
time to just
do nothing focus on nothing and that's
what puts you in the moment i also
figured
that when i perform on stage or in front
of camera
i am so much excited i am so much
interested i am
[Music]
and for the first time trust me in a
long time
i understood the true meaning of success
which was not
money plus recognition but it was
now plus excitement
i love this guy so much such a great
dude
now let me share another day's shots uh
story with you when i was in school four
to 5
30 p.m was the time and i was allowed to
go out and play
i was asked to be an engineer but the
entire day i was
i used to wait for 4pm to happen i would
step out and the next one and a half
hours
felt like five minutes
i didn't understand uh this then
but now wait honestly very confidently
i can tell you this that i am
living that 4 to 5
30 life right now since
cause and effects i know are not
different
excitement is the cause excitement is
the effect
i get hired again and again because all
these success
mantras that we talk about you know hard
work belief
focus vision risk taken talent
perseverance we can go on and on but all
these success mantras
are now the side effects of the process
itself
i'm so engaged i'm so it commands my
attention so much
that there is nothing else that you can
think about so hard work doesn't
feel it feels like hard work and there's
nothing else that you can do but to
a persist talent you will cultivate
vision you will get focus there is no
other way because it's it's
it's commanding your attention so much
so here i am right now five years
uh down the line money and fame
although still could not earn back their
reputation in my life
but let me show you one thing i have
much more of them than i had ever
planned
and the best thing uh my college
[Music]
one of the professors was very dear to
me calling me recently
about asking me to plan this interaction
with students
and i very humbly requested that can i
get my degree back
and it's uh it's happening and i'm
very excited again thank you so much
[Applause]
so good sorry i know this is very long
but he's such a cool dude such a smart
guy
such a good message as well i that i so
wholeheartedly believe in
just such a tragedy it really makes you
sad to think that he passed away
at such a young age and i think i
mentioned before in a video because
the police say he died from suicide and
at least personally someone that lives
in the moment
i cannot make sense out of committing
suicide
and there's a bit there's been this
whole controversy and and uh
theories about did he really what
happened people don't know and i don't
really want to get into that i wanted
this to just be a video of attributing
him because i think he's a cool dude
and i wanted to share with my audience
but yeah it's just this statement he had
about living in the moment i
obviously this was a couple years ago
but it this
you wouldn't commit suicide if you had
this mindset it just
i don't believe that at all i really
don't
uh but then again yeah it is a couple
years ago and i don't want to add things
to that but
that's just how i felt while listening
to it rest in peace or sean i would love
to meet you
seem like a [ __ ] awesome dude but i'm
really glad that you were you
thank you for being you and thank you
for watching this video i know it's a
bit different but that's it for now
them